he said this here you go okay i'll take  your questions and as usual folks they  gave me a list  of the people i'm going to choose  so uh jonathan associated press  okay wow so comparing this again we're  talking about quiet parts  that's all he does as a position of  strength  now here's the issue you would have with  donald trump if donald trump had been  given a list of reporters to call on and  uh they asked him about it you would say  no no it's my list  yeah  i made it because he understands that  you don't want to look like a puppet  former vice president joe biden uh also  confused putin with president trump i  caught part of president's uh trump  putin's uh  press conference  and he talked about the need for us to  be able to have some kind of modus  operandi where he dealt with making sure  the arctic was in fact  a free zone um